bonsoir stéphane ravier merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
marseille autrefois présenté comme le
bon élève est désormais dans le viseur à
les autorités maires et préfets
confondues constate une évolution je
suis défavorable est très rapide dans le
département des bouches du rhône une
réaction oui on parle beaucoup plus de
marseille et quand elle serait le soi
disant mauvais élèves que lorsqu'elle
était bonne élève
il ya quelques mois alors que l'épidémie
était jaillir juguler à marseille parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup de tests réalisés
en amont par un certain professeur raout
et qui proposait un traitement qui
n'était pas le sien il n'avait
absolument aucun dividende a touché dans
cette obtenir dans le dans l'utilisation
de ce2 ce2 ce traitement est bien
marseille on a un petit peu mis de côté
on a même vilipendé notre notre druide à
nous notre notre professeur out alors
aujourd'hui on s'acharne sur marseille
mais je constate comme 48 heures laval
le variant britannique a déjà fait mille
kilomètres puisqu'on le trouve désormais
à lille alors marseille n'est pas plus
mauvais élèves que les autres les
marseillais ont appliqué les consignes
sanitaires que le gouvernement nous a
infligé avec les résultats que l'on
connaît voilà les mesures coercitives
voire liberticide imposée par le
gouvernement manifestement ne savent ne
servent à rien il a tellement pris de
retard dans tous les domaines depuis le
mois de mars l'année dernière que eh
bien c'est la fuite en avant dans les
mesures liberticides qui nous impose il
y avait le couvre-feu à 22 heures puis
le couvre-feu à 20 heures le couvre feu
désormais à 18h pour marseille pour
l'ensemble des bouches du rhône sens que
vraiment cela n'améliore la situation
s'est donc les mesures de restriction
des libertés ne sont manifestement pas
les bonnes et pourtant stéphane ravier
la france ce n'est pas la plus
contrainte pour le moment vous le savez
y'a qu'a voir nos voisins justement
anglais qui sont reconfirmer de
recombiner totalement michel rubio l'art
votre ancien maire à marseille propose
d'ailleurs de reconstituer la ville
qu'en pensez-vous c'est trop selon vous
c'est excessif ont trop tard un homme
rubio un ami ruby y aurait là ce n'était
pas un maire c'était un éphémère merde
pendant pendant quelques semaines ou
quelques mois durant lesquels on nous
n'avons pas entendu aujourd'hui elle ne
cesse de s'exprimer avec un
positionnement qui va à l'encontre de
celui qui l'a remplacé justement au
poste de premier adjoint ne sont déjà
plus d'accord entre eux toujours plus de
rectrice de restrictions toujours plus
de contraintes
vous parliez du de l'exemple britannique
alors si les britanniques sont victimes
je dirais de mesures plus restrictives
qu'en france parce contre le l'objectif
du gouvernement britannique en matière
de vaccination puisque ça nous et ça
nous est présenté comme étant l' arme
absolue moi personnellement je ne me
ferai pas vacciner rassemblement
national laisse le libre choix aux
français en tout cas c'est notre ligne
moi je ne me ferai pas vacciner mais je
pense quand même à celles et ceux qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner je me
gênait blâme ni je les soutiens c'est
leur choix et bien en grande bretagne
l'objectif c'est de ces de vacciner 15
millions des sujets de sa majesté en
france et un million un million alors si
les britanniques sont qui sont confinés
ils ont quand même l'espoir dans
quelques semaines est bien de sortir de
cette crise sanitaire ce qui n'est pas
du tout le cas en france
nous cumulons des mois et des mois de
restriction de nos libertés et qu'ils
mettent en plus en danger notre économie
tout ça devient vraiment insupportable
mais tout de même stéphane ravier
il ya ce variant un britannique huit cas
détectés à marseille et pas seulement
vous l'avais dit à lille et sans doute
bientôt ailleurs
vous inquiète pas plus que cela parce
que vous dites voilà à trop de
restrictions en même temps le vaccin ne
me croyez pas alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour lutter contre ce virus selon vous
moi je ne dis pas que je ne crois pas
aux vaccins moi je dis qu'on va vous
faire vacciner vous aussi tous les
français pensent comme vous y a personne
qui se fait vacciner n'y a pas
d'immunité et on se confine pas non plus
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait et moi moi moi
je laisse les moi je moi je pense que
les français sont des adultes qui sont
doués de réflexion et c'est à eux se
faire un avis et apparaît à partir de là
à décider si oui ou non la vaccination
est le meilleur moyen pour lutter contre
cette épidémie on nous dit que oui et on
n'y met pas les moyens
encore une fois à marseille nous sommes
le 11 janvier bien le 8 janvier oui
c'est à 72 heures pour une ville de huit
cent soixante dix mille habitants
nous ne disposions que de cinq mille
doses de vaccin alors si elle est là la
réalité c'est parce que le gouvernement
a pris tellement de retard dans ce qu'il
a lui-même présenté comme étant l' arme
absolue contre contre cette épidémie
donc il a tellement pris de retard qu'il
est contraint par son incompétence par
son impréparation à a confiné à
incarcérer les marseillais et les
habitants des bouches du rhône en
général et puis d'autres départements
aujourd'hui c'est ça la réalité alors
vous l'avez dit l'exécutif qui table sur
un million de vaccinés d'ici la fin du
mois notamment grâce à l'arrivée du
vaccin modern art dont les 50 mille
premières doses sont acheminées dans le
grand test on le voit sur ces images
mais aussi en rhône alpes pardon
auvergne et rhône-alpes et on pas qu'un
chez vous ce vaccin d'ailleurs qui va se
conserver plus facilement parce qu'il a
besoin d'être conservée à moins 20
degrés contre moins 70 pour files r vous
êtes très méfiant contrairement
d'ailleurs au maire de marseille à
benoît paillard qui dit il faut se faire
vacciner au plus vite vous vous garder
une certaine réserve donc stéphane
ravier on l'aura compris alors je le dis
si tout à fait personnel c'est un choix
personnel ça n'engage que moi mais c'est
dans tous les sens du terme
je n'incite personne à faire comme moi
je n'incite personne à choisir le vaccin
je laisse je laisse la liberté de choix
à mes compatriotes
marcy et français en général qui doivent
se faire un avis sur la pertinence de ce
vaccin
personnellement j'estime ne pas avoir
assez de retour sur les conséquences de
cette vaccination
c'est le retour c'est pas le fait de
voilà de se faire vacciner dans l'absolu
c'est pour l'instant c'est trop tôt pour
vous n'avez pas eu ces eu de recul
notamment de la part des études
scientifiques
moi je crois avoir juste pas vérifié mon
mais mon carnet de vaccinations à jour
je ne suis pas un militant anti vaccins
ce que je constate là c'est qu'il ya
quand même beaucoup de zones d'ombré
d'incertitude j'ai pu participer chez
sur un plateau de haut niveau vos
confrères de télévision un débat il y à
une quinzaine de jours où il y avait
deux spécialistes une été ré était une
députée de la république en marche et
puis une autre médecin qui ont confronté
leurs points de vue sur cette
vaccination et sur ses conséquences
éventuelles et j'ai entendu le on ne
sait pas on verra
c'est un pari nous ne savons qu'au repas
finalement ce qui peut se passer ensuite
moi dans le tout dans le doute je
m'abstiens merci beaucoup en tout cas
stéphane ravier sénateurs n des bouches
du rhône présidence du groupe
rassemblement national on conseil
municipal de marseille merci d'avoir été
avec nous